let's take a look oh by the way alabama
did beat oklahoma
45 to 34 in that game let's take a look
at the power rankings
uh and let's start at the very top
christopher we've got the chief still at
number one the seahawks at two i've
moved your boy blue up to three and the
packers up to four because the patriots
lost and i dropped them to number six
let's just look at that top six yeah
chief seahawks bills
packers ravens patriots do you agree
with that
configuration i i believe i
do uh you know i would like quite
honestly
i'd probably still give the ravens the
lead over the bills and the packers
i would you know the fact that they just
lost you know they lost the chiefs it's
tough matchup
all that uh i probably would do that
that's the one that jumps out to me mike
and then the other one i think after
that that just
is a little surprising to me i would
prob i would put the buccaneers in front
of the patriots that's a tough one i
know because cam newton didn't play and
they still
are in that conversation but you know
i'm i'm
like really liking what i see in tampa
they're they have a chance to to really
be something here as we go forward
yeah okay let's say this yeah
hypothetically
right if the patriots and the buccaneers
were to play this weekend and cam
well you know and and everyone were
available for both teams yeah let's just
let's
if we're going to have a hypothetical
let's really make it hypothetical
who would who would you pick to win the
patriots of the bucks
based upon where they are right now
without the virus yeah right i got you i
got you
yeah you know that it'd be a close one i
probably
would give the edge to the patriots but
i wouldn't feel comfortable about it i
certainly wouldn't bet
so that's a good way to put it and yeah
maybe i would give them the edge it's
very very close not that i went through
that
mental gymnastics when i put the
patriots ahead of the buccaneers but
you know i kind of agree with you and i
think the benefit
that that bill belichick would have in
knowing tom brady for 20 years
would be very useful in coming up with a
defensive game plan but again
this isn't who would beat whom this
isn't a prediction of who's going to be
in the super bowl this is just where
the teams are now this is the barometer
yeah this is the
the snapshot after four weeks where the
teams are
um i've got the panthers
at number 15. okay and and i think the
panthers are very happy about that i
heard from someone with the panthers who
was amazed
by the fact that we have them at number
15 but
they've won two games in a row and
they they played well in the two games
they lost
yes they did they almost beat the
raiders they didn't embarrass themselves
against the buccaneers
this is a team that deserves to be right
in that you know
top half of the league just barely yeah
i i got no issue with that at all
i i don't know if i would have put them
you know one spot in front of the 49ers
i get it you know the 49ers the
quarterback play and you don't know
where that is and everything there but
uh to your point you know oh man you
know panthers are done christian
mccaffrey's hurt they won't be oh yeah
right okay
no the offense is good they got weapons
everywhere
the defense you know that's to me the
the surprising part of the football team
you know they give them a chance every
game they were phenomenal last week
against kyla murray and what they did
there to slow down that attack so
uh yeah not a lot of household names we
don't know a lot about them
but i i have a hard time arguing that
like i said the only team that i would
say
just that i feel wrong about there would
be to to have the 49ers
uh in front of them there's another team
in the top
16 though that i feel like you're
disrespecting
right now more than any other do you
want to guess who that is
who oh good guess um all right colts
i don't want to guess you tell me well
the cult of the team i look at right now
to go
number 11. yeah where who would you put
the put the graphic back i put them in
front of the titans the steelers the
saints
the titans are undefeated the steelers
are undefeated yeah i know i think i
would the colts
are i have a the colts have a chance
for me to be the this year's san
francisco 49ers from last year
i mean just it's their defense is scary
good
scary like that was a dominant effort
with the chicago bears i don't know if
chicago if they kept playing right now
would still score a touchdown in that
game i mean in that game in the
competitive part of the game
i mean they are it's very similar to
what i saw
last year the last few weeks when i
really dug in and watched colts i've
just been like
oh my gosh the defense you know the this
is where you look at like
sacks right they're like they have 10
sacks on the year which is like in the
middle of football
that's where it tells you sacks are
overrated at times they are
you know because the pressure on the
quarterback is every play
and uh i just think with that offense
and rivers has reigned it in a little
bit
i i that them and the bucks right now i
just go
watch out what i'm seeing formulating in
front of my eyes
i think there's like a chance to be two
teams to make a serious super bowl run
i've got the nfc east teams in the lower
half
all four of them in the bottom 16 the
cowboys at 17
eagles 22. washington 27 giants 31.
the eagles technically are in first
place points bet the official sports
betting partner of nbc sports
has the odds at dallas minus 118 meaning
you got to bet 118 dollars to win 100.
philadelphia at plus 120 bet 100 to win
120.
um is dallas in your mind still the
favorite even though they're 1-3
and their defense stinks i'd give them
i'd give them the slight edge over the
eagles close one though i mean it's
i don't know if i necessarily you know i
don't feel good about that but yeah with
those weapons
the offensive side of the ball the
defense i don't think it's going to be
able to get
much much better you know it might be a
little bit better than what we've seen
which has been like absolutely horrible
um but but yeah the eagles just
i i just you can't trust their offense i
guess that's where i come to
i just don't know even against bad
defenses i'm not sure if they can
capitalize
to take advantage of that i think it
would be a very close game but i think
right now i'd probably pick the cowboys
to win a close one
yeah i agree with you and i think the
cowboys are going to get better that's
going to be a topic that we
uh discuss in the next segment our draft
for today turn around candidates whether
it's players teams
units whatever but uh um do you
do you i still feel like the cowboys are
going to win that division oh although
you know what i felt like they were
going to win it all last year and what
happened they didn't
no i know i i don't know what to think
right now either you know the defense
being horrible
and you know so much being put on just
the offensive stars
to carry the team and as we've seen you
know one mess up when you play that way
one mess up one strip sack fumble you
know one ezekiel elliott fumble and all
of a sudden it's like whoa
we lost the possession they gained a
possession we were fine with being in a
shootout and you go i go you go i go
but now you go you go and we lost that
turn and
it just that that's how you know finite
the game is for the dallas cowboys right
now
let me just ask you this just because i
know we've kind of discussed this
i mean do you feel i just feel like the
afc
is you know head and shoulders better
than the nfc
like as far as complete football teams
are concerned yeah
you know right like you talk about the
nfc we go about the packers and the
seahawks the two best teams and i go
yeah quarterbacks off offense awesome
defense major question marks and i just
feel like i don't feel that way as much
in the
afc with some of their top teams no i
agree with you and you look at the afc
and uh about six of the top nine
teams in the power rankings are from the
afc and they've got a lot of great teams
right they've got a lot of teams that
and you know they may they may beat each
other up in the afc playoffs
and and make make the eventual super
bowl representative
more susceptible to losing to the
seahawks or the packers or the
buccaneers or whoever makes it out of
the nfc
but it's easier in the nfc to identify
the top teams yes
because because there's a gap already
between seahawks packers
buccaneers and everyone else and the
saints are in that yeah
right on the pool themselves yeah yeah
but i agree with you
i agree with you even though i think the
seahawks could probably beat
anyone from the nfc because of afc
excuse me because of russell wilson
the defense is a liability and if you
can contain russell wilson
you can blow the seahawks away because
they just can't stop you defense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports